what's going on guys this is Rob and
welcome back to geek culture explained
and in this video we're going to be
talking about the idea of King Thanos
and Avengers Kane Dynasty or Avengers
Secret Wars now as always if you guys
enjoy this video make sure you guys hit
the Subscribe button and make sure you
guys drop a like but for those of you
who do not know who King Thanos is this
guy is amazing so King Thanos was in a
story called Thanos wins which was
written by comic book writer Donnie
Cates the idea behind this is that as
Earth superheroes basically got older
Thanos got stronger because Thanos is an
eternal with a deviant Gene and he just
got stronger as time went on for any
number of reasons but ultimately Thanos
launched an attack against Earth and
basically killed everybody and then
following that he essentially killed
everything in the universe all the
cosmic entities Galactus the celestials
the whole nine yards until all that was
left was King Thanos and Cosmic ghost
writer you know what as a bonus let's
talk about Cosmic Ghost Rider I doubt
we'll see him in the MCU but it would be
cool to see so Cosmic Ghost Riders
actually Frank Castle The Punisher and
when Thanos was killing everybody on
Earth Frank Castle basically made a
statement with his dying breath which
was he would give anything to be able to
kill Thanos interim Mephisto who
basically made a deal with the Punisher
that he would give him the means to kill
Thanos but as always when it comes to
Mephisto there's a catch so he turned
Frank Castle into the Ghost Rider but he
couldn't leave Earth and that ultimately
Galactus showed up to consume the world
at some point and because Galactus was
one of the last beings Left Alive before
Thanos killed him the Galactus turned
Ghost Rider into his Herald and gave him
the power Cosmic hence the reason why
you have Cosmic Ghost Rider it's a
really cool story because of the way he
appeared everybody thought he was
Deadpool initially but the thing about
this is it's entirely possible for us to
see King Thanos in the MCU but not
exactly as his comic book version from
the Thanos when storyline instead we
could actually be seeing a comic book
faithful adaptation of Thanos in the m
to see you basically based on The
Infinity Gauntlet story combined with
just Thanos being Thanos so let's say in
this hypothetical situation with Thanos
in the Marvel Cinematic Universe King
Thanos that is let's say that we look at
the events of infinity war and Avengers
end game now as we saw that movie the
battle with Thanos was pretty small in
scope All Things Considered right you
basically had the Earthbound superheroes
facing off against Thanos and the
eternals chose not to step in for
reasons that nobody but Marvel Studios
understands because it's literally a
massive Calamity that would really just
negate the rules of the celestials and
just kind of require the eternals to
step in anyway but for whatever reason
they chose not to now the thing about
this is in this alternate reality let's
expand the scope of this conflict let's
say that Thanos blinking out half the
life in the universe is pretty massive
right say that it happened in Infinity
war and nobody really saw it coming
outside of the superheroes who were
there so that's why like the celestials
never stepped in or Galactus if he
exists in this alternate reality never
stepped in but by the time you get to
Avengers end game it's basically the
superheroes on Earth trying to prevent
Thanos from doing what he did before so
because that's the case the celestials
would know what Thanos goal is and a
Galactus if he exists in this universe
wouldn't know what his goal is assuming
that they weren't blinked out of
existence the snap was done at random so
you know half the celestials are gone
but let's say that in this alternate
reality because of everything going on
when it comes to the battle in Avengers
in-game the celestials step in and say
maybe Galactus steps in and potentially
a few other people the Silver Surfer or
what have you this leads to a massive
Universe wide battle which is actually
Thanos facing off against not just the
Earth superheroes but some of the most
powerful beings in existence and so
let's say that in this story Thanos gets
his hands on The Infinity Gauntlet and
Thanos snaps again and blinks out all
the at least half the life in the
universe that was just brought back but
let's say maybe he chooses to go a step
further maybe he becomes drunk with his
own power hour I would go as far as to
argue that the Thanos that we saw show
up in Avengers end game seemed a little
bit darker than the Thanos that we got
in Infinity war and so if that's being
the case let's say that he just gets
drunk with his own power whatever reason
that we choose to use Thanos takes it a
step further and says you know what
humanity and all these different races
are all just gonna procreate and they're
all gonna be right back where we were
before so let's just wipe out all life
in the universe and call it a day and
Thanos is the only guy there he's the
only resident there now whether or not
this would happen in that level of
extreme I'm not entirely sure you could
just say Thanos use is the infinity
gauntlets just make himself a demigod
right just kind of rule with an absolute
fist but the important thing here is
that if they were to give us this
version of Thanos if anything I think it
would be a cameo because the reality is
thanos's story is done there's no reason
to go back and retread The Infinity
Gauntlet stuff outside of simply just
the fact that we as fans will be
interested in seeing it what if the
events of infinity war and Avengers
in-game happen differently and Thanos
won then like Ultra ultimately how does
that play out right I mean we kind of
saw how that event transpired in
Infinity War but let's take it a step
further but I think that if you were to
appear it would be just some kind of
side-along universe or something that we
might Glimpse maybe a universe that Loki
passes through or one that Scotland
happens to witness an Ant-Man 3
quantumania assuming he explores the
Multiverse in any meaningful way but I
don't think he would be like a major
player I don't think there would be like
an entire TV show evolving around him I
don't think he'd be a major plot point
in any film but I do think it would be
cool to see a scenario where Thanos in
this alternate reality is closer in line
with this kind of aversion than the one
that we got in Infinity war in Avengers
endgame and just really over the course
of the first 10 years of the MCU heck
even if they want to they can invoke
mistress death and go back to the first
Avengers film when he was basically told
to challenge The Avengers is to court
death and the indication is that Thanos
is trying to gain the affections of Mr
Steph by basically killing everything he
can because he believes that will will
get him her favor it'd be cool to see
there's a variety of different ways that
you can do this but here's a question
that I have for you guys how many of you
would want to see King Thanos that
version of Thanos in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe a super powerful
version that killed every Cosmic entity
and every being across the whole
universe let me know if you guys want to
see that but with that being said we're
going to bring this video to an end
thank you guys for watching and I will
catch you all later
peace